[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
que los lleva a dar una vuelta al mundo
de la mano de nuestros periodistas soy
herminia Fernández por Andrés espinal en
Ucrania continúa en las exhumaciones en
el cementerio improvisado de las afueras
17 soldados ucranianos fueron enterrados
en una fosa común se ha descubierto que
443 tumbas individuales son de personas
re enterradas por los focales que
mantuvieron algunos registros sin
embargo Los investigadores ucranianos
dicen que es necesario sumar todos los
cuerpos para determinar la causa de la
muerte y las posibles pruebas de tortura
nuestro corresponsal Gulliver crack
realizó este reportaje que puede
resultar difícil de ver
Este cuerpo es exhumado y un criminólogo
comenzó el examen
primero la ropa
un civil
pronto se hace evidente que el hombre
tiene lesiones en la zona genital
[Música]
le indica un colega que eche un vistazo
están claramente perturbados por lo que
vengo
debido al Estado de putrefacción del
cuerpo se suspende el examen
Eso es todo es suficiente realmente
le oímos murmurar la palabra tortura
Pero no la repite ante la cámara está
prohibido dar conclusiones preliminares
solo los órganos judiciales sin
investigación pueden sacar conclusiones
Lo siento sin embargo los dirigentes
ucranianos no han dudado en afirmar que
algunas de las 460 personas enteradas
aquí fueron torturadas hasta la muerte
pero no tenemos ni idea de Cuántas la
mayoría de hecho murió bajo los
bombardeos cuando las fuerzas rusas
atacaron is you me marzo el primer día
de la exhumaciones y vio al personal de
una funeraria siendo interrogado por la
policía los días más tarde nos reunimos
con vital y el director de la empresa
que nos explicó que las personas habían
sido enterradas en tumbas poco profundas
en patios y Jardines de la ciudad los
rusos pidieron a su empresa que los
trasladarán fue necesario volver a
enterrarlos a todos como puedo
escribirselo es la guerra había
constantes bombardeos Así que la gente
acababa de ser enterrada allí donde
había muerto pero a veces los rusos le
pedían a vital y que enterrar a cuerpos
que Aparentemente no habían muerto en el
bombardeo
nos traían los cuerpos con las manos
atadas a la espalda
eso sugiere que ataron a la persona y la
torturaron Esa es mi opinión aunque no
puedo probarlo
los entierradores dijeron a la policía
que volvieron a sepultar al menos a 60
personas en tres lugares diferentes pero
que no los re enteraron a todos
la lucha contra el cambio climático no
pasa desapercibida en Qatar el país se
ha construido enormes estadios
climatizados para poder acoger la copa
del mundo que se llevará a cabo el
próximo mes de noviembre numerosos
obreros han trabajado en condiciones
deplorables lo cual ha causado miles de
Muertos algunas personalidades y ongs
han hecho el llamado boicotear el
mundial el informe es de francesto
estadios nuevos resplandecientes en la
mitad del desierto envueltos en polémica
derechos humanos señalados de ser
vulnerados y la preocupación de un
desastre ecológico a menos de dos meses
del mundial en Qatar varias
personalidades decidieron boicotear el
evento Yo el enamorado del fútbol
encontré mi voluntad toma una decisión
no miraré un solo partido de este
mundial
como a mí me gusta dormir tranquilamente
me gusta dormir diciéndome que no tengo
muchas cosas que reprocharme no voy a
ver el mundial de fútbol
para asegurar la construcción de
estadios climatizados hoteles y
estaciones de metro el país huésped tuvo
que llamar a millones de obreros
inmigrantes Pero desde el comienzo de
las obras muchos han denunciado sus
condiciones de trabajo provocando
incluso manifestaciones en marzo
prohibidas en Qatar según el medio de
comunicación de Garden cerca de 6.500
personas habrían perdido la vida en
estos lugares de trabajo tenemos dudas
muy serias sobre las condiciones de vida
sobre las condiciones de trabajo a 50
grados centígrados sin protección que
traen crisis cardíacas problemas
respiratorios entonces hay miles de
muertos
si nosotros en respuesta a estas
polémicas el medio le cotidiano del
territorio francés de ultramar la
reunión decidió boicotear la competición
es el primer medio francés en tomar
posición frente al mundial una decisión
que algunos simpatizantes no seguirán
No creo pienso que mi pasión y mi placer
me van a impedir boicotear un mundial
soy realmente fanático del fútbol y un
mundial es imperdible no será el caso
pero Confieso que con la polémica que
hay a veces me hago preguntas
la FIFA asegura que algunas de las
empresas que no respetaron las normas de
bienestar han indemnizado a sus
acelariados la organización afirma que
ya ha vendido cerca de dos millones y
medio de entradas
en Francia el sindicato cgt convocó una
manifestación de apoyo a las personas
que trabajan en las plataformas se
reparte en París los reclamos
condiciones laborales tarifas pero
también la regularización de estos
trabajadores que estuvieron en primera
línea Durante los peores momentos de la
pandemia Y que ahora se han convertido
en personas no Gratas las plataformas
desconectan cientos de cuentas cada
semana desafiando la legislación laboral
A qué juegan estas plataformas no los
explica nuestro equipo en París
Hace seis meses que además ya no tiene
derecho de trabajar para Uber eats
intenté conectarme pero no pude dos días
después recibí un correo electrónico
diciendo que mis papeles eran
fraudulentos y no eran válidos para una
cuenta de entrega Wow una desconexión
sin indemnización ni derecho al subsidio
por desempleo admite que sus papeles no
estaban en regla pero se sorprende de
kiuver its haya tardado cuatro años en
revisarlos
durante el Hobbit no nos pidieron los
papeles nos dejaron trabajar como
idiotas
señalamientos y presión del gobierno
jugadora al igual que otras plataformas
decidió limpiar las cuentas de los
repartidores el resultado 2.500
desconexiones de cuentas este verano
solo en la plataforma estadounidense con
la misma justificación los papeles
aportados son fraudulentos a mí tú sigue
teniendo derecho a trabajar pero no se
deja engañar según él la plataforma
pretende cumplir con la pero sin cambiar
realmente su funcionamiento
los documentos que no eran fraudulentos
hace un año hace dos años no eso y que
lo dirán y lo que es inaceptable V
reactiva otras cuentas con estos mismos
documentos hoy ante la polémica vr
emitió un comunicado para justificar
estas desconexiones pero rechaza
cualquier entrevista ante la cámara esta
situación no sorprende a Kevin motion
abogado especializado en derecho laboral
la plataforma se aprovecha de esto sabe
muy bien que existe esa población que
lleva meses y meses trabajando pero
cierra los ojos porque es la gente que
necesita para trabajar a bajo coste
Porque si volviera una población con
papeles no encontraría tanta gente para
trabajar a ese precio Así que cierra los
ojos las demandas se multiplican para
intentar cambiar las cosas pero está
solo en manos del gobierno hacerse el de
la vista gorda o regular de una vez por
todas esta situación
desde 1990 cada 28 de septiembre América
Latina y el Caribe conmemoran el día por
el derecho al aborto de las mujeres de
la región una fecha en la que reclaman
el acceso a la interrupción voluntaria
del embarazo este año Colombia está de
celebración luego de que el pasado 21 de
febrero la corte constitucional
despenalizar el delito del aborto
poniendo al país en la vanguardia en
materia de derechos sexuales y
reproductivos Marina cerdiña nos cuenta
la historia y los retos pendientes en la
implementación de la nueva ley
la emoción reflejado en los rostros de
estas jóvenes el 21 de febrero la corte
constitucional de Colombia sacó del
Código Penal el delito del aborto hasta
la semana 24 de gestación una decisión
histórica y El eco de las celebraciones
resuena de nuevo en las calles de Bogotá
el movimiento causa justa logró que el
alto tribunal emitiera la sentencia c055
Laura Castro vocera de la organización
reconoce que se han convertido en un
ejemplo para la región en materia de
derechos para las mujeres son una
invitación o un ejemplo de cómo la
movilización feminista y el litigio
estratégico está poniendo nuevos
argumentos y nuevos discursos para
reconocer los derechos de las mujeres y
es también una invitación a ver cada vez
más los procesos de movilización Social
del sur global desde 2006 Colombia
contaba con la sentencia c-355 el
sistema de tres causales que impera
también ahora para aquellas mujeres que
quieren interrumpir su embarazo a partir
de la semana 24
Las barreras para el acceso al aborto
siguen siendo amplias especialmente para
las mujeres Rurales y migrantes
Este es el informe no pasa por muchas
cosas que es una de las frases que nos
dijo una de las mujeres Venezolanas
entrevistada Juliana Martínez es la
autora del informe señala que una
barrera constante es la discriminación y
las violencias que sufren por ser
migrantes Las mayores barreras entre las
mujeres migrantes y regulares las viven
indudablemente las Caminantes de tener
el trayecto para acceder a la
interrupción voluntaria del embarazo
termina siendo a seguir haciendo ese
recorrido solas por lo tanto más
inseguras ser dejadas atrás y eso hace
que muchas veces ellas no estén
dispuestas a realizarse el procedimiento
aún cuando es su deseo el
desconocimiento del nuevo marco legal es
otra de las problemáticas que se suma a
la xenofobia nos plantea una de las
necesidades y es tener una visión más
integral de la salud sexual y la salud
reproductiva como parte del derecho a la
salud Colombia está en la vanguardia en
derechos reproductivos pero la
despenalización social del aborto y
universal sigue siendo una batalla de
largo aliento para el movimiento
feminista hasta aquí corresponsales de
la semana nuestro agradecimiento a
matorral librería por habernos cedido
las instalaciones para grabar Este
programa siga con más información en
francés 24 y 24.com